these are some of the pictures coming in
to us from the Turkish broadcaster NTV
which appeared to show military vehicles
along one of the bridges in Istanbul
we're also getting reports that footage
of tanks are the entrance to assembles
Ataturk Airport have been seen as well
so let me give you a little bit more
context Turkey's Prime Minister has
tonight said that a group within
Turkey's military has engaged in what he
said appeared to be an attempted coup
he's talked to NTV the broadcaster in
Turkey saying that it's correct there
was an attempt is what he says but it's
unclear whether or not the situation is
ongoing or not and the Prime Minister
Yildirim didn't provide any more detail
than that he did say that Turkey would
never allow any initiative that would
interrupt and democracy and all this
comes amid other reports coming in to us
from different news agencies from
Reuters to Associated Press suggesting
that military jets have been heard
flying over the capital Ankara also some
reports in the media suggesting that
ambulances were seen in front of turkeys
military headquarters other reports as
well suggesting that some gunshots have
been heard according to some witnesses
talking to the Reuters news agency as
well as these military jets and
helicopters seen flying overhead and as
we say we see those pictures of what
looks like military vehicles over
bridges the broadcast the NTV is
reported that both of Istanbul's bridges
across the Bosphorus which is the strait
separating the European and Asian sides
of the city had been closed to traffic
but it hasn't been clear whether all
these different events have been
connected until Turkey's Prime Minister
has spoken to the national broadcaster
suggesting that he believed what appear
to be an attempted coup had been going
on he does use the past tense he said
it's correct that there was an attempt
but it's not clear whether or not the
situation is ongoing